my iPad for the most part has replaced
my Sketchbook and so in this video I'm
going to show you three different ways
that I use my iPad for work
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel my
name is dammy and I am an architect in
beautiful Vancouver BC on this channel
we talk about architecture and design
and also some tools and strategies that
can help us have more meaningful and
fulfilling careers in architecture
paper is still a very big part of my
workflow especially when I'm working
with my colleagues or when we're doing
design reviews and I do think there's
certain things that paper and a fat
marker just can't beat but after seeing
some other Architects like Henry GAO or
Eric Reinhold transformed their workflow
with the iPad I decided to get one for
myself and over the last year or so it's
become a really essential part of my
workflow I use a combination of
procreate notability click up and PDF
for work and I'm going to show you how I
use that here
one of the ways I maximize the use of my
iPad as an architect is with these
graphic templates I created these
templates and brush presets based on the
things I use every single day and I've
got things from people and tree brushes
to scale paper templates basically every
time I start a new project I start with
this and it saves me tons and tons of
time all of these templates that I'm
using in this video are going to be
available at the link in the description
so the first way I use the iPad is for
design iterations as a design tool in
the earlier phases of the design so when
you're in the schematic phases of the
design you don't really want to spend
too much time fully developing one
option you want to try doing multiple
iterations and spend that time to
develop multiple rough options and
that's because you can have a much
better discussion this way like you can
talk about the pros and cons of each
option and you can collaboratively pick
an option to develop more in detail
which is why in this phase Architects
tend to draw things out on paper because
you can think faster and draw faster
than doing it on the computer but the
problem with this of course is that hand
sketched floor plans are not nearly as
accurate as floor plans made on cat or
Revit and it gets messy very fast I
actually used to spend a lot of time
just drawing and redrawing things
because even though the ideas were
worked out oh it just didn't look clean
enough to be presentable and I think we
can all agree the presentability of the
thing has a lot to do with how your work
is perceived then there's the scanning
and printing again and there's just a
lot of wasted time and paper in this
process so now with my iPad almost all
of these inefficiencies have been
resolved
I use procreate and I have a set of
templates that I use whenever I start a
project I start with my scale paper
template which I've set up in different
metric or imperial scales in different
paper sizes I have it on about 30
opacity and you can turn it off before
you print or you can leave it on if you
want we typically print in tabloid so
this is the one that I use the most and
because of these one meter grids I can
get a much higher level of accuracy much
faster even when I'm just doing a
schematic layout while I'm working on
projects with existing conditions I
would model the building and Revit based
on the existing drawings that are
available and use the PDF of the
drawings as the base the best thing
about using the iPad is the ability to
make options with layers and easily go
back if you make a mistake without
having to restart or erase things once
I've got the basic layout out I have a
set of scale furniture elements that I
can easily copy and paste into the
drawings or I use these stamp brush
tools which I have saved onto my
procreate app
when I'm developing the elevations I add
color and tone with a brush set that
kind of mimics markers and you can
overlay them and the lines get darker
and thicker and I feel like this just
adds a richness to the drawings
I've also been collecting different
background images that I've been using
to stylize the drawings and I don't use
this too much when I'm working but I
find that it just adds another level of
depth when presenting it digitally and
you can also play around with materials
with this as well when we move into 3D
as soon as the Design's been roughly
modeled in Revit I take a couple of
views of areas that needs to be resolved
and then I print a PDF of those views
and I use them as a base for drawing
over
and it's the same idea as the plans I
don't want to spend too much time
detailing one option before discussing
it with your team
you want to do a couple of iterations to
talk about the general direction of the
building
rather than spending all your time in
one option the problem with when you're
modeling things on the computer
especially in 3D especially in Revit is
that you tend to waste a lot of time
trying to resolve details that are
actually not that necessary and like
trying to make the image look nice and I
think there's something to be said about
the look of a 3D rendering like a rough
3D rendering in my opinion looks a lot
less presentable than a rough sketch
like a rough hand sketch even for
internal reviews a rough hand sketch by
its nature feels more like a work in
progress and it's more open for
discussion because with procreate you
can just simply go back if you make a
mistake your sketches end up coming out
a lot more refined and presentable than
a sketch over Trace
[Music]
another way I use my iPad is for site
reviews before I have my iPad I would
carry around like a full set of drawings
in one hand and my phone in the other
and I would be taking photos while at
the same time trying to make notes on my
drawings and a lot of the times I would
be flipping through the pages and
walking around and if you're a very
experienced architect who knows the ins
and outs of construction you might not
need the drawings as much but as a
fairly new architect you know I want to
double check everything and document
everything as someone who's always been
a little bit self-conscious about going
to slate
wall because I don't always look like I
belong there
I'm always kind of looking for ways for
me to look more confident and feel more
confident
and so the iPad has been great for that
because I can have all my information
right here
and during construction you will
inevitably come across things that you
don't really understand but that's
totally okay and that's what your team's
there for
but if you are on site alone or you're
still a fairly new architect one of the
best ways to build confidence is just to
be overly prepared like read all of the
rfis before you get to the meeting and
if you know that something's being built
while you're there try to anticipate the
problems before you get there and if I
don't understand something on site I'll
say something like can you explain the
problem from start to finish and you
might feel kind of stupid at the moment
but most people are more than happy to
walk you through the problem and it
actually makes you look more thorough
and like you're taking ownership of the
problem
I have my drawings and I upload them to
notability which is basically just like
a note-taking software and as I'm
walking around the site I take photos
and I insert them directly into the
pages and from there I can take
dimensions and write notes on the spot
[Music]
I'll also pull up click up on my split
screen which is where I organize all my
project notes and throughout the weeks I
will make notes on any concerns or
things I want to check out when I'm on
site and when I get there I can go
through the list and just check them off
sketching directly on the photos is also
the best way for me to communicate with
contractors or Consultants because they
don't really need pretty images they
just need the essential information but
usually they needed that information
like yesterday so doing a quick sketch
on my iPad is usually the fastest way
for me to send off that information
the most common way to use the iPad is
for markups we used to print tons and
tons of sheets of paper to mark up
construction sets but now we can just
mark it up on the iPad I use a simple
PDF program to annotate and I mean yeah
that's pretty much it if you're
interested in the design process and how
I develop concepts for a real project
I'll leave the video right here if
you're interested in any of these
graphic assets that I use with my iPad
setup I have fully downloadable
templates from scale grids to trees to
Furniture elements to people elements
and I'll leave the links to all of this
in the description there are also other
ways that I use my iPad for architecture
and also for non-architecture stuff so
if you have any specific questions or
want me to make a video on anything just
let me know down in the comments
remember to like this video if you found
it helpful and hit the Bell if you want
to be notified as soon as I release a
new video and if you haven't subscribed
subscribe and with that I'll see you
guys in the next video
foreign
[Music]